Burnie macfay smick Sanders joins the
2020 race Kamala Harris and Cory Booker
gets stuck in the Jessie Smollett trap
and a CBS reporter blows the lid off a
bias in the media I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
oh man so much news Bernie's jumping
back in the race and all the
septuagenarian Marxists are up in arms
well actually they can't actually walk
so they're mostly just wheeling around
they're very excited though and they
would be shouting if they had vocal
cords left but they're kind of old we'll
get to all of that in just one second
first let's talk about the fact that not
only are a lot of old Bernie Sanders
voters nearing their doom so are you
everybody is we're all approaching death
I mean an uplifting message today here
on the bench Shapiro show that's why you
need life insurance life insurance is
one of those topics everybody knows a
little bit about but do you understand
it well enough to feel comfortable
buying it whether you're an insurance
expert or a newbie
policy genius has created a website that
makes it easy for you to compare quotes
get advice and get covered policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford
from there you just apply online and the
advisers that policy genius will handle
all the red tape for you they will even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company no extra fees no Commission
sales agents just helpful advice and
personalized service and policy genius
doesn't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance and homeowners
insurance and auto insurance they can
help you get covered fast so no matter
how much or how little you know about
life insurance you can find the right
policy in minutes at policy genius.com
that's policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance it is the
responsible thing to do if you are
interested in adopting you need to make
sure that you and your family are taken
care of in case god forbid of an
emergency like this policy genius.com
the easy way to compare and buy life
insurance all right so the big breaking
news this morning
bunny is in that means it's time for
Bernie's theme song
according to Politico Bernie Sanders is
jumping into the race and this is very
exciting stuff the New York Times says
senator Bernie Sanders the Vermont
independent and 2016 Democratic primary
runner-up whose populist policy agenda
has how pushed the party to the left
announced on Tuesday that he was running
for president again embarking on a bid
that would test whether he could retain
the anti-establishment appeal he enjoyed
with many liberal voters three years ago
a self-styled Democratic Socialist whose
calls for Medicare for all a $15 minimum
wage and tuition free public colleges
have become pillars of the parties left
wing Mr Sanders is among the best known
politicians to join an already crowded
Democratic field and one of the most
outspoken against President Trump whom
he has repeatedly called a pathological
liar and a racist three years ago there
in got 2016 campaign when we brought
forth our progressive agenda we were
told that our ideas were radical and
ox-3
he said on Tuesday in an early morning
email to supporters citing health
economic and education policies well
three years have come and gone and I am
merely a little older and they have a
little less hair and as a result of
millions of Americans now standing up
and fighting back all of these policies
and more are now supported by a majority
of Americans by the way that is a lie if
you look at the actual polling with
regard to Medicare for all
and then people are told that their
taxes will increase Medicare and and
private insurance will be abolished the
support for Medicare for all drops to 27
percent as far as the idea that people
are for free college tuition depends on
if you tell them the cost as far as his
beliefs that we should completely
regulate and tax the economy out of
existence most people not super
interested in that the good news for
Bernie Sanders is that of course he is
very prominent because of 2016 and now
he is going to crowd out senator
Elizabeth Warren of Massachusetts you
know Elizabeth Warren was hoping that
she could pick up sort of the Bernie
mantel she missed her shot that was 2016
she could have competed with him she
could have al competed I I think of
Elizabeth Warren had run in 2016 there's
a good shot she might be president right
now I think now her time has passed they
left her behind on the plains where she
will roam around looking for Buffalo
senator Elizabeth Warren Massachusetts
the progressive wing of the party is
going to swing behind Bernie Sanders who
really does have an amazing 2020 slogan
if you want the guy who actually knew
Karl Marx that's that's gonna be Bernie
slogan all these other people they're
just imitating Bernie Sanders is the
real deal
he used to sit around in British pubs
and talk with Karl Marx Karl Marx would
be like you know what would be great is
if we level the playing field and better
be like I love this idea that is a
terrific idea would you like another
share of this pudding and Karl Marx like
pudding hasn't been invented yet but
that's how in any case Bernie Sanders
did put out a twenty20 commercial and
it's just as terrible as you would think
it would be here is Bernie Sanders his
initial twenty20 commercial defecates
place from the top on down but always
from the bottom on up
please stop again for second question he
says real change takes place from the
taught and it doesn't take place from
the top down it comes from the bottom up
he is for a centralized economy his
entire platform is centralization of
everything in top-down authority what in
the world is he even talking about so
what he's saying is lots of people want
this
therefore it is ground-up changed not
top-down change but here's the way it
works things grow from the ground up and
then we dictate them from the top down
and then the people on the ground up if
they don't agree with us we kill them
like the kulaks hey his his silly
commercial continues Bernie Sanders
health care for all idea is gaining
steam free tuition free college tuition
free tuition champion
Bernie Sanders added the greatest threat
to national security is kind of change
the future of our planet is at stake
Sanders taking on Amazon Bernie Sanders
has been consistent hammering about
income inequality
nobody in America works 40 hours a week
should be living in poverty so economy
is rigged we have a campaign finance
system which is corrupt brothers and
sisters we have a lot of work in front
of us
all righty so when one of the things I
love about Bernie Sanders is that
basically he just sits there and
complains about the state of things as
they are Bernie Sanders was so lazy when
he was in a commune in the 1970s that
they threw him out of the commune he was
spending his days basically sitting
around writing weird erotic columns
about women who wish they had been raped
I'm not kidding about this and then they
threw him out of the communist they're
like dude you're not productive enough
to be in a commune he has spent his
entire career in the Senate doing
nothing no things and then he's there he
is talking about the most prosperous
economy in the history of the world most
powerful economy in the history of the
world it's rigged it's a rigged economy
you know it's rigged the fact that you
do nothing your entire life and now
you're gonna run for president and in
the first three and a half hours of your
campaign you raise a million dollars
that seems kind of rigged to me I'll be
honest with you it seems to me like if
you get to live off the fat of the land
as Bernie Sanders has about producing
nothing for your entire life and that
guy is as old as my grandparents that's
a pretty amazing life right there so you
don't get to whine about how terrible
America is when you have done zero
things your entire life of use to a
human and yet here you are as a
front-runner in a presidential race he
also made a public announcement of his
run for the presidency in 2020 in front
of the press here's what he had to say
hi I'm Bernie Sanders I'm running for
president our campaign is not only about
the feeding Donald Trump the most
dangerous president in modern American
history our campaign is about redoubling
our efforts to end racism sexism
homophobia religious bigotry and all
forms of discrimination
I have a question how just hell that's
my real question you know they're a
bunch of questionable statements that he
makes it first of all I'm not sure that
he can actually run for president at
this point he's more like hobbling the
president but then again I am Todd
luring for president but I mean the
guy's a tea I love the fact that he
thinks that nobody in the Democratic
Party is capable of picking up his
mantle he says he's for the people he
says he's for his ideas he's 80 years
old there are people who are
legitimately half his age made over work
he's like half his age and he's like
nope you know they can't handle it it's
got to be me only I have the vision to
see that's only three types of deal
unnecessary on the shelves of America's
supermarkets also bread lines are great
because it's a line for bread
we like bread we like lines so why would
we not like bread lines
he actually said in the 1980s he likes
bread lines by the way that's not just
me making that up when he says that he's
going to run to end racism sexism
bigotry and homophobia really how how's
that gonna work because it seems to me
that Bernie Sanders and a lot of the
Democratic Party are spending an awful
lot of time actually ratcheting up
racism sexism bigotry anti religious
sentiment it seems like they are the
ones who are interested in separating
Americans from Americans Bernie Sanders
is 2020 campaign has already been
maligned by the left as racist no joke
people on the Left think that Bernie
Sanders his campaign is not
intersectional enough the rip on him
there was an article in The New York
Times two days ago about how Bernie
Sanders was too white to win about how
Bernie Sanders had alienated too many
minority people to win and he's gonna
run to end racism sexism bigotry and
homophobia that that's as Bernie Sanders
his platform sure I think he continues
along these lines running against a
president who is a pathological liar a
fraud a racist a sexist a xenophobe
and someone who was undermining American
democracy as he leads us in an
authoritarian direction I am running for
president because now more than ever we
need leadership that brings us together
not divides us up nothing brings us
together quite lated like a communist
dictatorship nothing brings you together
quite like the regime's that Bernie
Sanders has expressed admiration for
Cuba brings people together the USSR
brings people together
Venezuela brings people together so many
wonderful places that bring people to
now listen I'm only half joking because
the reality is Bernie did express a lot
of support for these sorts of regimes
only in the last ten years or so has he
decided that actually he isn't like Cuba
and the USSR as much as he used to now
he likes Denmark and Norway and the
Scandinavian democratic socialist
countries now he's a Democratic
Socialist he's not an actual socialist
when he makes his entire campaign about
I'm gonna unify everyone also the
current president in the White House is
the wolf post input of ever lived and I
hope he steps on a landmine if that's
your campaign and your campaign is that
is rife with racism sexism bigotry and
homophobia you're not a unifier now what
is Bernie Sanders his path to the
nomination his path to the nomination is
basically everybody splits the vote and
he runs up the left that's basically his
path to the nomination he hopes that
bado and and Kamala and Cory book her
Club each other to death like baby seals
and then he just sort of hobbles his way
across the finish line
his pollsters are basically suggesting
this already at Politico Politico says
when Bernie Sanders was mulling a 20/20
campaign last year he said he would
likely pull the trigger if he thought he
was the best candidate to defeat
President Trump now that he's officially
in the race for the White House a key
element of his argument is that he is in
a way that flies in the face of
conventional wisdom his campaign is
gearing up to take aim at one of the
central cases made against him that the
77 year old Democratic Socialist far
from being unable to win a general
election could blaze a non-traditional
path to victory on the electoral map
unlike any other Democratic candidate
this month Ben Tolkien who is Sanders
pollster circulated a memo about an
online survey he conducted in late 2017
for progressives who are hoping to flip
state legislative seats in West Virginia
the poll found that Sanders would beat
Trump by two percentage points in the
state despite the fact that Trump won
West Virginia 69 to 27 and that no
Democratic presidential candidate has
carried the state since 1996 in a second
I'm discuss some more of the polling for
Bernie Sanders and why he is a different
sort of candidate than Kamala Harris or
even beta O'Rourke first let's talk
about that back pain you've been having
says may sound kind of weird but hanging
upside down actually a really good way
to decompress the back and joints after
a workout and boost recovery this is
called the inversion therapy it uses
gravity and your own body weight to
decompress the spine and release tension
in your shoulders neck and joints
inverting after workout boosts the
recovery process by stretching and
elongating your spine and joints
rehydrating the disks and relaxing tired
muscles this is why over three million
people have put their trust in teeter
the best inversion table on the market
they've been the best known name in
inversion tables since 1981
I love the teeter inversion table every
time I workout I go home get on that
table you know basically hang upside
down and by the time I'm done I'm
feeling a lot better they're offering a
great deal right now just for my
listeners for a limited time you can get
a brand new 2019 Teeter Fit spine
inversion table model with bonus
accessories and a free pair of gravity
boots so you can invert at home or take
the boots with you to the gym cheater
inversion table
have thousands of reviews on Amazon with
an average 4.6 star rating and with this
deal you get 150 bucks off when you go
to teeter calm slash Ben you also get
free shipping free returns a 60 day
money back guarantee there's no risk to
you to try it out remember you can only
get the new 20:19 teeter fits by an
inversion table plus a free pair of
gravity boots by going to teeter comm
slash Ben that is te e ter calm / ben
teeter calm / benton go check it out
right now for the special deal all right
so the pollsters are basically saying
that Sanders could defeat Trump in a
variety of largely white non-college
educated states some of the Sanders camp
according to Politico envision possibly
making a play for Iowa Ohio and Indiana
as well as Kansas North and South Dakota
Nebraska Oklahoma and Montana six states
that together have voted for the
Democratic nominee just twice in the
past half century his pollster says it
could radically change the map as Bernie
has shown as Trump has shown I don't
think we are in a binary two-dimensional
left-right paradigm anymore now there is
some truth to this and the truth is that
a full 12% of Bernie Sanders primary
voters said they voted for Donald Trump
in the general election because they
wanted somebody who's anti-establishment
who had that populist feel and who
actually believed that a lot of these
guys who were non college educated white
folks in Ohio and Iowa and and variety
of these other states Michigan Wisconsin
that those people actually had dignity I
had a conversation with Arthur Brooks
over at the American Enterprise
Institute yesterday and in his book that
is coming out very soon you should go
check it out it's called love your
enemies not out for a couple of weeks
but in his book he talks about how he
believes the reason that President Trump
won the presidency is because Trump
granted the feeling of dignity to a lot
of non college educated white folks who
had been ignored by the prevailing
sentiments in academia and on the coasts
that basically these guys were gonna be
left behind well Bernie Sanders does
cater to that crowd in a way that no
other Democrat does Elizabeth Warren is
still an elitist for all of the populist
talk she's a professor at Harvard hey
this is a woman who was very elite and
Kamala Harris is pursuing a completely
different electoral strategy her
electoral strategy is to mimic the
Barack Obama coalition the
intersectional coalition get heavy black
turnout bring along a lot of Hispanics
and young people and women that's gonna
be the coalition Bernie Sanders is more
of a throwback the only two candidates
in the Democratic field so far who have
any appeal really in places like
Michigan Wisconsin Ohio
the only two Democrats are Joe Biden and
Bernie Sanders both old white guys who
have sort of a blue-collar feel so it is
not out of the realm of possibility that
Bernie Sanders is dangerous in a general
election that's not out of the realm of
possibility at all and in a primary he
does well with the progressive wing he's
done surprisingly well with young people
as well could he gain momentum again
sure why not
or theoretically he could kind of fall
off the table a little bit you could see
a Ron Paul effect to a Ron Paul the
first time you run this does decently
attendant said degrade over time Pappy
Kenan had the same thing in 1992 he saw
the same thing with Ross Perot between
1992 and 1996 you could see a falling
off in support for Bernie Sanders but
he's dangerous and he raises a lot of
money he raises a lot of money I'm gonna
talk a little bit more about Bernie
Sanders in just one second according to
an analysis of exit polling in twenty
five primaries according to Politico
Bernie Sanders narrowly won black voters
under 30 in 2016 but he lost older
african-americans by large margins they
turned out at higher rates than their
younger counterparts to beat Trump the
Democratic nominee will need robust
support from black voters the most loyal
part of the party's base well that or he
needs to peel off a bunch of those
blue-collar white voters again and he
does have a problem in these primaries
in 2016 who's running against an
unlikable old white woman Hillary
Clinton she was not drawing heavily well
like she didn't do well him in with the
black community or as well as Barack
Obama did in the prop and the party
primaries again it was Hillary Clinton's
weakness with black primary voters in
2008 that led Barack Obama to steal the
nomination from her Sanders almost stole
the nomination from her again because
she was weak among black voters this
time you've got two black candidates in
Camilla Harris and Cory Booker both of
whom have robust appeal among black
voters in the democratic party primaries
with that said with that said he is
running from behind in in in those
particular areas but in several recent
20/20 surveys he is actually in first
place among Latinos faring better than
even former Vice President Joe Biden so
you know we can dismiss Bernie Sanders
as a has-been or we can face the reality
that the guy has a real shot at the
nomination he does have a shot at the
nomination and he has pushed the
Democratic Party laughs he can fairly
say that he has helped push the
Democratic Party far to the left and
some of his opponents are making Boo
Boo's it's really interesting so Kamala
Harris do a bit of a 20
20 roundup so let's bring that Kamala
Harris theme music into play Pamela
Harris this is her problem
Bernie Sanders's outflanking her on the
left so she tried very early on to
co-opt his medicare-for-all appeal and
then she had to walk it back she said
let's get rid of private insurance and
then within 48 hours she said no I
didn't really mean that Bernie Sanders
has no problem with that he'll just say
it straight out which is very appealing
for the party base well yesterday she
was asked specifically about Bernie
Sanders and her response was well I'm
not really a Democratic Socialist I am
NOT a Democratic Socialist
I believe that what what voters do want
is they want to know that whoever is
going to leave understands that in
America today not everyone has an equal
opportunity to an access to a path to
success and that that has been building
up over decades and we've got a correct
course okay I am NOT a Democratic
Socialist is gonna be a hard sell with
the Democratic Party base remember aoc
who's probably the most popular female
in the Democratic Party right now is a
self-described Democratic Socialist
Bernie Sanders is a self-described
Democratic Socialist Hillary Clinton
admitted after the 2016 election that it
hurt her to say she was Pro capitalism
in the Democratic primaries and the
Democratic Party has moved significantly
to the left even since 2016 so if Kamala
is going to campaign to the right of
Bernie Sanders that does open a pretty
wide lane for Bernie Sanders Plus as it
turns out there are a lot of holes in
Kamala Harris's record so for example
Kamala Harris who I think right now has
to be seen as the 2020 frontrunner until
Joe Biden jumps into the race at least
combo Harris
she says she was doing a big rally last
night in Portsmouth I do love how the
media cover these rallies oh my goodness
1,500 people showed up for a Kamala
Harris rally in Portsmouth New Hampshire
yeah like that I mean I'm sorry I'm not
impressed by 1500 people every speech I
give at every College in the country is
1,500 people that is that is not a huge
number of people and if it is then I
should run for president my goodness
anyway Kamala Harris says we haven't put
resources into our education system
again because of her past as a
prosecutor in the state of California it
makes her difficult to make arguments
like this
that we have failed to put the resources
into our public education system and
instead we are putting tons of money
into a system of mass incarceration
[Applause]
that's a hard sell from nark Kamala
Harris who spent a lot of time putting a
lot of people behind bars in the state
of California and then had her own
attorneys arguing that people should not
be let out on two-for-one deals because
we need to make sure that we have enough
cheap labor to clean up wildfire areas
that lady is going to be arguing against
mass incarceration if you think Bernie
ain't gonna slap her on that you are
totally wrong he's going to politically
slap her around on that and the far left
of the party doesn't like Kamala Harris
young people are not thrilled with
Kamala Harris so she's got a problem
here by the way she happens to be
completely wrong prison spending in the
states is still a fraction of overall
pre-k through 12 education spending
according to that noted right-wing
source the Washington Post state spends
71 billion dollars on prisons and five
hundred thirty four billion dollars on
schools every year so when she talks
about us spending money on prisons and
not on schools that is simply not true
by the way I've always wondered when
people talk about mass incarceration
which people are gonna let out of prison
and don't tell me the people who smoke
pot and are in prison for smoking pot
because that's no-one in prison by
percentage the number of people who are
in prison for smoking pot is
extraordinarily low and usually it was
bargained down from dealing drugs now if
you want to end the war on drugs cuz you
think that's bad policy that's one thing
but if you want to suggest that people
haven't broken serious laws and are in
prison for no reason
that obviously is untrue if you want to
talk about the lowering crime rates over
the last thirty years you're gonna have
to talk about the massive increase in
the number of criminals who have
actually been in prison
here's the thing if canola actually
board a campaign as an open prosecutor
I'm not sure that that doesn't happen
over appeal then this newfangled far
left stick that she has been pushing but
again there is a window open here for
Bernie Sanders to run to her left and
the same is true with regard to Amy
clobber charge so Amy Klobuchar the
senator from Minnesota who threw her hat
into the ring in the middle of the snow
in Minnesota would you have some ami
Club a chart theme music I think we do
Fargo's ami Club HR who it turns out is
not the cop in Fargo she's the person
throwing people into the wood chipper
she is running as a moderate as well
which opens the window again to Bernie
Sanders and someone further to her left
now plop a chart has been attempting to
move further to her left she suggested
that she was in favor of banning
semi-automatic weapons yesterday in a
nationally televised interview here was
Amy Klobuchar
suggesting that her new gun policy was
to ban a bunch of guns Minnesota is a
state that values the outdoors we value
hunting and fishing and so I come at it
from a little different place than some
of my colleagues that are running for
this office and that I always look at
every proposal and say would this hurt
my uncle dick in the deer stand and I
would say that these common-sense
proposals in front of us do not I don't
see banning assault weapons right I
don't think that hurts in the deer stand
okay banning semi-automatic weapons does
in fact hurt in the deer stand because
those are all the hunting weapons I'm
just gonna use a bolt-action rifle from
World War two if you're using a
semiautomatic rifle in the United States
for hunting that is pretty much all the
rifles in the United States because all
that means is every time you pull the
trigger a bullet fires that's all the
semi-automatic weapon is okay in just a
second we're gonna get why Amy Klobuchar
is is also becoming unpopular with her
own basin and some holes in her
candidacy in just a second first let's
talk about black rifle coffee morning
coffee is an American institution that's
why when it comes to starting my day I
reach for the most American coffee on
the market I'm talking about black rifle
coffee I love black rifle coffee you
know I've only become a coffee fan in
the last couple of years as my kids have
gotten a little bit older and waking me
up earlier in the morning and now that
I'm getting up drinking coffee black
rifle coffee is certainly my choice
black rifle coffee gives a portion of
their sales to veteran and first
responder causes black rifle coffee is
roast to order guarantee new fresh
delicious coffee with every single order
black rifles coffee club makes things
easy you just pick your blend in the
amount you want and black rifle ships
your coffee right to your door every
month hassle free wake up with America's
coffee black rifle coffee visit black
rifle coffee calm slash man or see 15%
off your order that is black rifle
coffee dot-com slash Ben for 15% off
black rifle coffee calm slash Ben it's
great coffee and I know the
you founded the company this is not some
weak Mead PC company the folks we found
in black rifle coffee are solid
conservatives go check out black rifle
coffee calm slash been for 15% off that
is black rifle coffee calm slash ban the
coffee is just fantastic go check them
out right now
alrighty so amy klobuchar also got
herself into some hot water yesterday
because she was asked about her record
of abusing employees allegedly abusing
employees as in like throwing binders at
them and what was hilarious about this
is that she got angry while being asked
about abusing her own employees yes have
I pushed people to a hard yes but I have
kept expectations for myself that are
very high I've asked my staff to meet
those same expectations and that the big
point for me is I want the country to
meet high expectations
man it's a good thing that guy is more
than 20 feet away from her she would
have taken that chair and chucked it at
him it really would've gotten ugly so in
any case what you see is that in the
Democratic Party a lot of the top
candidates aren't far enough left to
stop Bernie Sanders from racing around
the outside from racing around the
outside and it's driving members of the
Democratic Party to be more and more
radical including on issues where they
have made fools of themselves
the most obvious issue is in the jesse
smaller case so the jesse smaller case
to recap was an obvious hoax from the
very beginning you weren't allowed to
say that but the reality was there are
too many holes in the story for it not
to have been at least questionable from
the very beginning well now we know why
Empire actor Jesse small and apparently
was trying to make a stink out of a
story that never happened he suggested
that it's 2:00 a.m. on Chicago streets
in the middle of a polar vortex a couple
of Magha fans were walking around
decided to attack him because they
watched Empire which makes perfect sense
and then throw a rope around his neck
throw bleach on him shout the F&N words
at him and then shout this is Magga
country in Chicago at 2:00 a.m. in the
middle of a polar vortex while he was
holding a Subway sandwich which he never
relinquished so there are a lot of
questions about this that did not stop
both Cory Booker and Camilla Harris from
calling it a modern day lynching and now
we find out that he is basically
suspected of paying two of his friends
to attack him a week
sir a letter was sent to him now this
letter that was sent to him supposedly
was mailed to Chicago's Cinna space
studios where the show empire is filmed
the letter prompted a hazmat response
apparently there was a white substance
in the letter which was determined to be
aspirin the note was crafted with
letters apparently cut out from
magazines to form words and the piece
together message contained racial and
homophobic threats directed at Smollett
apparently they are now examining
whether or not smell it was behind the
letter as well that is the rumor today
so good times there that did not stop
all the Democrats from attempting to
leap to the left on this particular
issue to prove their bona fide ease on
issues of race so you'll remember that
Spartacus Cory Booker so we have some
Spartacus music for Senator Cory Booker
of New Jersey we do there he is senator
Cory Booker of New Jersey you'll recall
that he tweeted out that this was a
modern day lynching did Spartacus and
then he was asked about it yesterday and
he said well maybe it wasn't true but it
sort of felt true
so whatever we'll pretend it happened or
not well you know what you know what
let's wait for the facts to come out so
they it happens
modern day lynching day that it all
falls apart gotta wait for the facts to
come out guys very Spartacus like you
know this is a guy who really is out
front and honest what a rebel he is my
goodness well the informations still
coming out and I'm gonna withhold until
all the information actually comes out
from on-the-record sources we know in
America that bigoted and biased attacks
are on the rise in a serious way what
we're seeing is attacks on people
because they're different and we all
need to join together and condemn those
attacks okay so yeah well his whole
shtick is that well it may not be
factually true it is morally true and
then it's not just him it is also
commonly Harris or Carla Harris her
awkwardness yesterday did not merely
stop it at her campaigns and she tweeted
out on the day that this happened that
was a modern day lynching so there's an
attempted modern day lynching then
yesterday she was asked about this tweet
and things went wildly wrong for the
senator from California which tweet what
tweet about saying that it is a modern
day lynching that
sorry Oh does he smell it
okay so I will say this about that case
I think that the facts are still
unfolding and I'm very concerned
oh she's concerned and the facts are
unfolding but they weren't unfolding
when it first happened then then we knew
what what the case was but now they're
unfolding again it's a great clip man I
love the fact that she first reacts like
I did what know what who made tweet are
you talking to me and she actually books
behind her she actually looks behind her
like are you talking to the person
behind me no senator we're talking to
you
then she they asked her didn't she what
about your tweet centers they heard you
do it a bit like what did that doesn't
that's not even English senator Babb
nezzie glad his role well was ever do it
senator
you're gonna need to speak English what
I mean to say what I mean to say says
Kamala Harris is that we are all part of
a greater force a greater life force
that unites you and the rock and the
tree so do I exist do my tweets exist or
is there a force that unifies us flows
through us unifies everything the
attempted misdirection by Kamala Harris
is just wonderful it's just wonderful
but again one of the beautiful things
about Bernie Sanders joining the party
is that everybody is now going to be
forced to the dramatic left because they
have to head him off at the past no the
good news is that they have members of
the media who are going to defend them
at all costs there's a news article a
news article not a commentary article a
news article from the New York Times
titled Republicans hope to sway voters
with labels that demonize Democrats so
just to get this straight you have
running for the Democratic presidential
nomination an open democratic socialist
who hopes to nationalize vast swathes of
American industry in Bernie Sanders you
have a Democratic Party that embraces
abortion two points of birth and you
have a Democratic Party that has
embraced open anti-semites inside its
own ranks but it's Republicans
mislabeling that's the real story the
media is worth 8 to 10 points for
Democrats in every national election
there's just no way around this this
piece from Cheryl gates Stolberg at the
New York Times is insane
it's again this is not a piece of
commentary it is reported news quote in
the one hundred and sixteenth Congress
if you're a Democrat you're either a
socialist a baby killer or an
anti-semite when I first read that line
I was like oh good finally the New York
Times is covering the news rejection of
late and then they continue that at
least is what Republicans want voters to
think as they seek to demonize Democrats
well in advance of the 2020 elections by
painting them as left wing crazies
who'll destroy the American economy
murder newborn babies and turn a blind
eye to bigotry against Jews okay like
that's what they say that's not even
what we say that is what they themselves
have said this is what Democrats
themselves have said they've said they
want to radically increase taxes if
they're honest they mean on all tax
brackets including people who are
middle-class they once you radically
regulate the American economy they want
a green new deal that will supposedly
end all use of carbon-based fuels they
say they say that they want to kill
babies to point to birth they want that
to be legal and the governor of Virginia
said even after birth and they obviously
are turning a blind eye to bigotry
against Jews that's not a Republican
painting that's reality but according to
the New York Times the real story is
that Republicans are mean to Democrats
because Republicans keep pouncing and
seizing Republicans amped it up they
seized on a Twitter post by a freshman
representative Ilhan Omar of Minnesota
which even some Democrats contends is
anti-semitic
well then Republicans didn't seize on it
did they if Democrats also say something
is anti-semitic and Republicans say
something is anti-semitic the story is
not Republican seizing it's the
anti-semitism when they say the
president Trump is radical and when he
calls for people to stop adopting
socialism in our country Bernie Sanders
a Democratic frontrunner is an open
democratic socialist it's not our fault
that the Democratic Party has decided to
move radically to the left House
Republicans have identified 55 Democrats
they regard as vulnerable including many
freshmen some flipped Republican seats
last year some represent districts
carried by Trump in 2016 some are held
in distance are in districts held by
Republicans until recently bruised by
their losses last year Republicans are
determined to start earlier and be more
aggressive on the offense in 2020 and
are hoping to exploit the Democratic
presidential candidates courtship of the
left again it is wonderful to be a
member of the media where every story
about Democrats moving to the left is
really about the evils of the Republican
Party okay in just a second we're going
to
talk about media bias writ large because
a couple of revelations yesterday that
are quite stunning first let's talk
about making your business more
efficient hiring used to be difficult
multiple job site stacks of resumes a
confusing review process but today hiren
can actually be easy and you only have
to go to one place to get it done that's
zip recruiter comm slash daily wire zip
recruiter sends your job to over a
hundred of the web's leading job boards
but they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology zip
recruiter scans thousands of resumes to
find people with the right experience
and them invite them to apply to your
job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes everyone and spots
like spotlights the top candidates so
you never miss a great match zip
recruiter is so effective that eighty
percent of employers who post on zip
recruiter can equality cans in it
through the site within the first day
and right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter dot-com slash
daily wire that is zip recruiter comm
slash daily wired Dai ly WI re zip
recruiter com
slash daily wire zip recruiter is indeed
the smartest way to hire zip recruiter
com slash daily wire go check them out
right now make your business more
efficient make sure that your hiring is
done at the highest possible level zip
recruiter comm slash daily Wired's who
tries to procore for free zip recruit is
calm slash daily wire alright so I want
to talk about a pretty amazing
revelation from CBS's Laura Logan in
just a second but you're gonna have to
go and subscribe over at daily wire calm
when you do you get the rest of the show
live you get two additional hours of the
show every day yesterday's show if you
missed it we did like a full hour on
George Washington and honor of
presidency is really fun and it was
really great if I do say so myself
there's great material every day that
you are missing if you're not actually
subscribing over at daily wire comm and
getting two additional hours per day
also it is almost time for our next
episode of the conversation tonight 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific the awful
Michael Knowles will be taking your
questions and answering them live on air
as always
Alicia Krauss the lovely will be hosting
and keeping Knowles in check this
episode will be free for everyone to
watch on Facebook and YouTube only
subscribers can ask the questions once
again subscribe to get your questions
answered by Michael Knowles tonight at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific
join the conversation of all sorts of
goodies for you when you become a member
and for an annual membership you get
this the greatest of all beverage
vessels the leftist here's hot or cold
tumbler now remember when you get that
annual subscription and you get the
leftist here's hut or cold tumbler if
you
Instagram or tweet out a photo of
yourself with the tumblr and the hashtag
leftist here's tumblr if you go check
that out then we will actually mention
you on the show your picture may appear
on the show which would be I mean come
on
a dream come true let's be honest so go
check that out right now for $99 you're
also subscribed at YouTube and iTunes
leave us a review it always helps we're
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so the good news for Democrats of course
is that the media will always defend
everything that they do and what's
hilarious about the media is that so
many members of the media refuse to
acknowledge the bias that exists in
their own space now this is particularly
weird because a lot of prevailing
left-wing theory has always been about
the notion that ideas are stand-in for
power if you go and listen to any
critical studies lecture on college
campuses what they say is that any
system of human interaction is
structured based on power hierarchies so
for example folks on the Left will argue
that the free market in which you and I
exchange goods and services is not
actually free it's a system of
exploitation pressed upon other people
by people who happen to have the power
in any given society and we can just
restructure that system at will they
make this argument about free speech
there's a philosopher named Marxist
neo-marxist philosopher named bear mark
used in the 1960s and 1970s he made the
case that essentially free speech itself
was a weaponized version of power
because the people who are most loud and
most likely to be heard were
representatives of the power hierarchy
and therefore what would be best for the
dispossessed is to shut down certain
types of speech in favor of other types
of speech so the left is constantly
seeing things in terms of power
relationships this is why they see every
disparity as an example of
discrimination this is why folks on the
Left constantly look at any sort of
inequality and they see it as inequity
they see one group that is poorer than
another group and instead of them seeing
that as maybe that's the outcome based
on individual decision making maybe
that's the result of historical
discrimination but not current day
discrimination instead they say this
must be the result of power hierarchies
on in place preventing one group from
rising to the level of the other group
now usually that's not true but the
point I'm making is that the left is
constantly seeing human behavior as a
reflection of the need to defend some
sort of power hierarchy except when it
comes to the leftist media when it comes
to the leftist media then it's just
objectivity then it's just we're just
speaking the truth it is not a
reflection of a power hierarchy in which
people at the top of the media happen to
be Democrats and push a Democrat point
of view their views that they push in
the pages of the New York Times and on
the airwaves at CNN or CBS or ABC none
of
as a reflection of a power dominance by
folks who are on the left instead that
is just them telling the truth their
opinion is not opinion it's fact their
power is not power it's reality and you
can see this from folks on the Left who
ignored their own theories about power
that apply everywhere except to them
it's really quite amazing so for example
Jonathan Capehart
over at though he's a columnist for The
Washington Post not been columnist for
The Washington Post he said that the
reason a lot of people believe the story
about jussie Smollett is because it fit
in with reality well only if you are of
a certain political view but folks in
the left media tend to substitute the
idea that their opinions are actually
fact they believe that fact and their
opinions are one in the same so here is
Jonathan Capehart saying something that
is actually not particularly true but
saying it with the full confidence of
fact behind it because of course the
media is not left and their opinions are
not reflections of opinions or
reflections of their desire for power
their opinions are reflections of
reality the circumstances and the way he
told the story and it's and what
happened he said happened to him sort of
fit in with an era not a narrative but a
reality for a lot of people in this
country since President Trump was
inaugurated that there is it that there
is a an atmosphere of menace and an
atmosphere of hate around the country
that made it possible for people to
rather readily believe or want to
believe justice Millette there's such a
fascinating Freudian slip in the middle
of that clip where Jonathan Capehart
this MSNBC contributor columnist for The
Washington Post where capehart says that
there is this that this story fit in
with a narrative there not a narrative a
reality the conflation of a narrative
with a reality the conflation of a story
you want to tell about America with the
reality of the situation in America it's
really indicative of the fact that for a
lot of folks on the Left they believe
their opinions are fact and they believe
facts are merely somebody else's opinion
it truly is incredible and then they
have the temerity to claim that they are
the objective truth tellers when it
comes to media dominance than it is not
in fact that they dominate the power
hierarchies of a lot of media companies
and that's why the opinions are what
they are at a lot of media companies now
as it turns out none of that is true the
reason that the media are many
mainstream media institutions are to the
left is because the
people on top of those institutions are
to the left CBS's Lara Logan who's been
a top-line reporter for a very long time
at CBS
she basically let this slip she was
doing an interview and it's pretty
scorched earth interview actually she
was doing it the interview with retired
Navy SEAL Mike Ritland about a variety
of topics for his mic drop podcast and
she said listen the media like to
pretend they're objective they are not
objective in the slightest media
everywhere is mostly liberal not just in
the US but in this country eighty-five
percent of journalists are registered
Democrats so that's just a fact because
although the media has always been
historically always been left-leaning
we've abandoned our pretense or at least
the effort to be objective today that
means we've become political activists
in a sense and some could argue
propagandists right and there's some
merit to that and she is exactly right
about this but she let this build now
this is nothing new
Bernard Goldberg wrote a book I think is
back in 2001 almost 20 years ago he was
also from CBS a top-line reporter saying
exactly this that there's massive media
bias and she of course is not the only
one saying this Jill Abramson is the New
York Times former executive editor she
bashed the paper for its unmistakeably
anti Trump editorial direction
apparently Abramson slammed her
successor Dean Baquet saying he's
endangered The Times his credibility by
boosting their readership with constant
catering to anti-trump audiences
according to media ight Abramson wrote
quote the baquette said publicly he
didn't want The Times to be the
opposition party his news pages were
unmistakeably anti-trump some headlines
contained raw opinion as did some of the
stories that were labeled as news
analysis it is obvious that the media in
other words are very much the lefty now
they're people like brian Stelter and
they say well why are you using the term
of the media broadly speaking the answer
is it's shorthand people who listen to
the show know what I'm talking about
when I say the media they know that I'm
not talking about the minority of media
like Fox News or Daily wire or Daily
Caller they know that I'm talking about
ABC NBC CBS MSNBC CNN the New York Times
The Washington Post the Boston Globe the
LA Times the Chicago Tribune they know
that I'm talking about the vast majority
of news organs in the United States who
all share the same editorial slant
and they all see how it's shared the
same editorial slant on jussie Smollett
I mean it's it's pretty amazing they
share the same editorial slant when it
comes to the coverage of the 2020
presidential race so when Lara Logan
breaks the front and she says guys like
everyone knows what it is that you are
when she says that it's treated by the
media with with shock and awe again this
runs directly counter to their own
prevailing critical studies theories
about literally everything in life the
left believes in the area of law that
all judicial decisions are actually not
based on judicial principles they are
based on what the judges preferred
political outcomes should be now what's
amazing about all of this is that if you
are going to accuse one side or the
other of manipulating law for power
purposes it would have to be the
political left that does this on a more
frequent basis if you're going to accuse
one side of manipulating the facts on a
political basis it would have to be the
left in fact I think there's a lot of
projection that goes on on the political
left I'm not talking about specific
individuals here I'm talking about a
generalized mindset that exists in a lot
of places in the legal infrastructure in
the media infrastructure in the
Hollywood infrastructure there's a
belief in a lot of these halls of power
that it is fine to manipulate facts
because again if everything is a power
relationship why would we not use our
power in order to push views that are
good and true and wonderful and convince
ourselves in the process that we are
doing something positive and good and
objectively objectively necessary you
know the reason that President Trump
exists one of the reasons president
Trump's exists is because the right
began to feel like the left was
manipulating the institutions of our
public life in order to use their power
to cram down certain political opinions
and Trump was a giant middle finger to
that that Trump was essentially saying
to all of these institutions you've
controlled the narrative too too long
for too long and so I'm just going to
ignore whatever a narrative it is that
you wish to choose and then the left
accuses President Trump of being a liar
and they accuse President Trump of
manipulating the facts and a lot of
people on the right say well yeah you
guys have been participating in this too
the problem is when both sides tend to
agree that there are no more neutral
principles when but when the left which
has decided there are no neutral
principles in law in journalism there
are no neutral principles there is just
our opinion which is fact and then the
right decides well look the left
believes that so why shouldn't our
opinion also be treated
fact when there are no more neutral
principles this is how a country falls
apart media bias is not dangerous merely
because it's propaganda media bias is
not merely dangerous because it pushes a
particular political point of view media
bias is dangerous because it undermines
the fundamental neutral principles on
which the country is based and on which
Western civilization is based Western
civilization science politics they're
all based on the idea that reason can
separate out opinion from fact that we
can all agree on a set of facts and then
we can draw our opinions from that set
of facts the opinions may vary but the
facts are the same when when the Left
decided in the 1960s that all human
interactions were based on power
relationships and that even facts
themselves were subject to the vagaries
of these power dynamics that you
couldn't even say factual things because
the factual things themselves were no
longer factual they were just a
reflection of power once the left
decided that we've lost all common
ground we can't even agree on a set of
facts anymore so you have one side
arguing from one set of opinions and one
side arguing from another set of
opinions and there is no meeting of the
minds what's fascinating about all of
this is that you see it really play out
in the political sphere most and when we
actually get together in person it tends
to dissipate it's really fascinating I
was talking to a friend in the Senate
who talks with Democrats in places like
the Senate Judiciary Committee all the
time and what this person said is that
if you actually talk with Democrats when
they are not on mic they actually act a
lot more reasonable they are willing to
acknowledge that there is a middle
ground they're willing to acknowledge a
common basis of principle in fact but
once they get on camera and that splits
immediately because when it comes time
to exercise power the exercise of power
is seen as self-justifying that's deeply
dangerous stuff and when the right
responds by saying the exercise of power
is self is self justifying that the left
is doing it anyway the left is just
engaged in this this cramdown so we may
as well engage in our cram downs as well
then how are we supposed to have a
conversation if every conversation is
just a competition in power dynamics
there is no conversation at all we're
just armwrestling for who gets to
control the government and the levers of
power in the United States already time
for some things I like and then some
things that I hate so things I like
president Trump has been saying some
very good and useful things
about the situation in Venezuela nicolas
maduro who's the socialist dictator of
venezuela still has not left thank god
there's not been massive violence
breaking out as of yet but president
Trump continues to put the pressure on
Maduro to leave incredibly there are
members of the Venezuelan military still
barely supporting this failed
dictatorship they are risking their
future they are risking their lives and
Venezuela's future for a man controlled
by the Cuban military and protected by a
private army of Cuban soldiers Maduro is
not a Venezuelan Patriot he is a Cuban
puppet that's what he is
he's a president Trump is of course
right to push this it just shows the
polarity in our politics but this is
controversial Maduro is one of the worst
dictators on planet earth and yet you
see a lot of members of the left coming
out to defend him it's it's pretty
astonishing and the media will cover for
those members Ilhan omar is still being
covered for she's out there full-scale
defending Maduro and we are supposed to
pretend that she should sit on the House
Foreign Affairs Committee and that's
totally normal
very very very odd okay time for a
couple of things that I hate thing I
hate number one there's a new study out
that shows that the vast majority of
citizens in the United States could not
pass a basic citizenship test the only
state in the United States where people
passed a US citizenship test or the
majority passed the US citizenship test
the only state in America is Vermont
ironically the home of Bernie Sanders
who barely missed being a Soviet citizen
apparently there there's some highlights
from the survey which was conducted for
the for the Woodrow Wilson national
fellowship foundation by Linkin Park
strategies people did relatively well on
some basic questions seven out of ten
new Thomas Jefferson wrote the
Declaration of Independence and that FDR
was president during World War two
but only 43% knew that Woodrow Wilson
was president during World War one
nearly one in four thought it was
Roosevelt only 56 percent knew which
countries we fought in World War two
fewer than one-third could correctly
name three of the original States which
is kind of devastating I mean they're
all along the eastern seaboard guys more
than six out of ten incorrectly thought
that the Constitution was written in
1776 nearly four out of ten
but Benjamin Franklin invented the light
bulb so I think looked it as Woodrow
Wilson said democracy is the worst
system except for all the other it does
show that we have a serious education
problem in our in our country and that
education problem is not about the
problems of our history it's about like
very very basic things like what our
country is about and who the people were
who founded it and what year things
happen we have a serious disconnect
between what people ought to know about
their own country and what they actually
do know other things that I hate you
have to admire how all of the hubbub
around Virginia just died out remember
one two weeks ago the big story was that
all three of the Virginia top officials
were in trouble that the governor of
Virginia Ralph Northam had tried to moon
his wah moonwalk his way out of trouble
not from being caught with a picture in
his yearbook of a guy in blackface and
another person in a KKK outfit and then
Ralph Northam suggesting that he didn't
do that but he did dress as Michael
Jackson for a dance-off in 1985 and then
him trying to fit his way out of it
remember that and then you remember his
lieutenant governor was credibly accused
of two separate sexual assaults murder
how that sort of disappeared from the
news there's an op-ed today in the
Washington Post from Meredith Watson
who's one of the accusers says I'm
willing to testify in public just in
Fairfax should - well that's good I mean
I'm glad that she's willing to come
forward and testify in public I just
find it fascinating how good for the
Washington Post for running this but
let's just say that it would be on the
front page of every newspaper in America
every single day if a prominent
Republican official had been twice
accused credibly of sexual assault and
then stayed in office without attempting
to refute the allegations in any serious
way according to the Washington Post
op-ed by the way Fairfax denied that he
raped me and he denied Tyson's account
as well and from any of the public the
media and the Virginia General Assembly
that was that in one week they moved on
if if just in Fairfax were a Republican
they would not have moved on in one week
that is for damn sure
okay so a little bit later today we will
be back for two additional hours of the
Ben Shapiro show so stick around for
that go subscribe go check it out right
now I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19